High-profile actors are known for making inflated
salaries, but not every coveted role comes
with a hefty paycheck.
We've pulled together a few of the most iconic
roles in the last 30 years that earned actors
next to nothing—at least by Hollywood standards.
Barkhad Abdi in Captain Phillips
A 2014 profile in the New Yorker revealed
that Barkhad Abdi made just $65,000 for his
role as a Somali pirate in the 2013 blockbuster
drama Captain Phillips.
While that may seem like a pretty decent sum
of cash to regular Joes, it's really nothing
when you consider the movie cost $55 million
to make, and who knows how much of that went
to star Tom Hanks.
Fortunately for Abdi, the risk seems to have
paid off.
Not only did he win a BAFTA for his critically
acclaimed performance, he went on to earn
Oscar and Golden Globe nominations, as well.
"Look at me."
"Sure."
"I'm the captain now."
Jonah Hill in The Wolf of Wall Street
With a directing career that includes iconic
movies like Taxi Driver and Raging Bull, it's
no wonder actors are willing to do most anything
to be cast in a Martin Scorsese picture.
Included on that list: Jonah Hill, who agreed
to the Screen Actor Guild's minimum wage of
$60,000 to shoot 2013's The Wolf of Wall Street
over seven months.
Sure, $60,000 is nothing compared to the $25
million salary that star Leonardo DiCaprio
made for the same movie.
But considering Hill got a surprise Oscar
nomination for his insane performance in a
Martin Scorsese movie, he probably couldn't
care less.
Brad Pitt in Thelma & Louise
Brad Pitt's star-is-born performance as Geena
Davis' roadside lover in 1991's Thelma & Louise
may have put him on the road to success, but
the role reportedly came with a less-than-sexy
paycheck.
Multiple sources have reported that the then-twenty-something
hunk earned a measly $6,000 for his performance.
Of course, almost 10 years later, Pitt was
already making upwards of $17 million per
movie and hit the $20 million mark by 2005's
Mr. & Mrs. Smith.
Hilary Swank in Boys Don't Cry
The heartbreaking 1999 bio-pic Boys Don't
Cry, about a woman choosing to live as a man,
cost a reported $2 million to make, almost
none of which went to its star, Hilary Swank.
The actress herself has admitted this in numerous
interviews, adding her salary was so low,
she couldn't even qualify for health insurance.
Fortunately, her dire financial situation
soon took a turn for the much, much better.
After winning a Best Actress Oscar, Swank
made a reported $3 million for her follow-up
movie, 2001's The Affair of the Necklace.
Bill Murray in Rushmore
In the 2013 book, The Wes Anderson Collection,
writer Matt Zoller Seitz revealed that Bill
Murray earned roughly $9,000 for his performance
in 1998's Rushmore.
Plus, when the film's studio, Disney-owned
Touchstone Pictures, refused to pay for a
helicopter for the movie, Murray personally
wrote Anderson a check for $25,000 to cover
the cost.
Anderson reportedly never even cashed it.
Oprah Winfrey in The Color Purple
Today, legendary talk show host, mogul, and
actress Oprah Winfrey's net worth is estimated
at around $3 billion, but even Oprah had to
start from the bottom and work her way up.
According to music icon Quincy Jones, who
co-produced Winfrey's debut film, 1985's The
Color Purple, Winfrey earned a measly $35,000
for her work on Steven Spielberg's epic.
The film ultimately took in almost $200 million
worldwide off a $14 million budget.
Ryan Gosling in Half Nelson
The budget for 2006 indie drama Half Nelson
was so tight that star Ryan Gosling had to
agree to shoot the movie for $1,000 a week—way
less than some of the high-profile films he'd
previously made in Hollywood.
But like most of the stars on our list, Gosling's
low salary ultimately yielded high returns,
including an Oscar nomination for his critically
acclaimed performance.
He reportedly made a cool $1 million-plus
for his follow-up movie, Fracture, and is
one of the most sought-after actors in the
business today.
Tom Cruise in Magnolia
By the time Paul Thomas Anderson's Magnolia
came around, superstar Tom Cruise could afford
to take a pay cut here and there.
Still, it's pretty remarkable to just how
low his salary actually dropped.
According to multiple reports, Cruise made
just $100,000 for Anderson's drama, next to
nothing compared to the jaw-dropping $20 million
he made that same year for Stanley Kubrick's
final film, Eyes Wide Shut …
"I will not apologize for what I want!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!